VOICE OVER: How well do we
understand facial expressions?
LISA FELDMAN BARRETT: Emotional expressions are
much more nuanced and variable than
people have assumed.
VOICE OVER: And do our faces reliably express our feelings?
What emotion is this person feeling?
What about this one?
RACHAEL JACK: We can use facial
expressions to communicate how we're
feeling and but it can also
reflect different personality traits.
VOICE OVER: Is this person distraught
or elated?
Furious
or celebratory?
LISA: The interest in facial expressions and
the modern science of emotion really began
in the 1960s with a scientist named
Silvan Tomkins and two of his
postdoctoral fellows Paul Ekman and Cal Izard.
They were very interested in
testing the hypothesis that
everyone around the world
scowls when they're angry, smiles when
they're happy, and correspondingly that
everyone around the world recognises
those facial movements as expressions of emotion.
VOICE OVER: These ideas stood largely
unchallenged for a generation but many
researchers now believe that the
picture is a lot more nuanced.
LISA: What we're dealing with is highly variable,
highly context sensitive,
temporarily changing patterns.
VOICE OVER: And these contexts are one of the key
factors researchers are investigating as
they try to understand facial
expressions.
LISA: While people are moving their faces
they're also speaking, there are
acoustical changes in the vocalisations
there are body postures. The person
carries around with them a whole
internal context of their body and then
there's the external context you know
who else is present? What kind of
situation are they in? What are they doing?
And then there's a temporal
context and all of that contextual
information really matters.
So whereas scientists used to focus
primarily on the face now they're
focusing more on faces in context.
VOICE OVER: Research into expressions has typically
relied on showing subjects posed
photographs of faces
representing different emotions
but photographs like this are often just
faces in isolation with no context at all.
Also, because they are static they
lack the temporal context which could be
read in a moving face.
What's more the researchers have to
start by assigning emotions to
expressions which can introduce biases
and subjectivity. To get around this
researchers are turning to technology to
find more neutral ways
of studying emotion.
RACHAEL: The approach that we take is
more of a bottom-up, objective approach.
VOICE OVER: Rachael Jack's research uses a computer
which randomly generates
dynamic facial expressions.
RACHAEL: We've used this really to
look at the main differences between
cultures in terms of the six classic
emotions; happy, surprise, fear, disgust,
anger and sad, and we found that East
Asian facial expressions of these
emotions tend to be signaled primarily
with the eye region, so the eyebrows and
differences in the eyes. Whereas with
Westerners the face movements tended to
vary more in the mouth region.
These differences, also, in the location of
expressivity on the face, is mirrored
very nicely in cultural emoticons.
So in western emoticons what you find is
that there's two eyes and then the mouth
tends to vary to be able to express
sadness, happiness and so on, and it's the
opposite pattern with East Asian
emoticons in that the mouth is either
minimized or it's completely absent and
it's the variance of the eyes which
communicates different emotion messages.
VOICE OVER: Differences like this are leading some
researchers to believe the expressions
are not as universal as once thought and
that some behaviours might be learnt in childhood.
LISA: What's happening in early
childhood is emotion knowledge is being
bootstrapped into the brain, into the
brain's wiring. This is also what happens
when you change cultures when you move
from one culture to another culture you
have to learn what is the nod of a
head or the or the raise of a lip or
the shake of a head you know what do
these things actually mean in this culture.
VOICE OVER: Despite these complexities
the idea that facial expressions could
be used as a way to read emotions has
excited big business.
Leading tech companies have already started
developing algorithms to detect
expressions and one estimate suggests
the industry could be worth fifty six
billion dollars by 2024. Systems are
already being trialed and marketed in a
wide variety of fields.
LISA: For hiring purposes, in educational settings,
in security settings, and in certain places
even in legal settings.
VOICE OVER: But despite the
predictions many scientists
think that claims software could
read emotion may be premature.
RACHAEL: We often make facial
expressions that convey an emotion
message but doesn't necessarily mean
that we have this emotion inside so
oftentimes we smile out of politeness, we
want to convey to the other person that
you know they're welcome etc. But this
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
experiencing an emotion. The other
challenge is that it could be very
easy to trick automatic facial
expression detection systems. So we may
want the system to believe that we are
feeling sad or happy and so it'd be
quite easy for a human then to
create, to generate realistic
facial expressions that could trick a system.